네, 안녕하세요. 오늘 드라이브스루
어 역삼동 편을 준비했습니다.
역삼동은 제가 첫 창업했던 동네이기도
하고 어 역삼동이 뭐 개발되는 과정
그리고 실제로 역삼동에 저희가 중계를
좀 많이 하고 있는데 좀 어떤 것들이
최근에 거래됐고 요즘 분위기는 어떤지
좀 알아보도록 하겠습니다. 여기는
사실 사람이 다니는 곳이 아닙니다.
임대가 쉽지 않아요. 여기 대로변은
특히 네. 지금도 보시면 알겠지만
유동인구가 거의 없습니다. 사람이
많은 곳 다니는 곳은 아니지만 여기도
다 비어 있네요. 찬 적이 없습니다.
물론 이제 지어진지 얼마 되진
않았지만 임대가 어 한 번도 되지
않았어요. 그리고 요거는 저희가
리모델링에서 최근에 통임대
맞췄습니다. 통임대 맞췄고 여기
언주집 여기 집에서 처음 시작했어요.
길산남 월세 70만 원에서 어남이
시작한 곳입니다. 여기 어 주택에서
처음 시작했고 그때는 진짜 아무것도
없었어요. 진짜 제 책상밖에
없었습니다. 아무것도 없이 창업했는데
다행히 뭐 시기도 시기지만 좋은
분들이 좀 많이 도와주셔 가지고 지금
이렇게까지 된 거 같습니다. 좌측에
있는게 얼마 전에 75억이 정도의
매각 됐는데 지금 리모델링 공사
중입니다. 그래서 저기는 뭐 그래도
도로 조건도 그렇고 위치도 그렇고
금액대도 괜찮게 매입한 거 같아요.
그래서 리모델링 하고 있고. 그리고
이쪽 표현은 1종입니다. 네.
일종이고 이쪽 동네가 좀 이렇게 뭐
미용실이라든지 요런 원룸이 안에 많이
밀집되어 있습니다. 그리고 종종 이제
사무실이라든지 이런 것들이 좀 있고
일단 제가 최근에 매각된 사례 중에
좀 인상깊게 봤었던 사례가 몇 개
있어요. 좀 현장 가서 설명을 좀
드릴게요.
여기가 도로 조건이 어 좋지가
않습니다. 여기 대로변에
최근에 팔린 사례가 있습니다. 커피빈
있던 건물이 매각이 되는데 그게
대지평당 한 거의 2억 5천만 원
정도에 매각이 됐어요. 네. 총
메가로 치면은 뭐 245억 정도
됩니다.
>> 역삼동 2억 5천이면은 어느
정도인가요?
>> 그래도 여기 대로변 코너여서 위치는
굉장히 좋은데 여기 이제 그 전에
매각 진행할 때 명도 조건이었거든요.
금액도 좀 더 많이 비쌌는데 좀 많이
절충이 된다 매각됐습니다. 요게
커피요 건물이에요.
네. 평당 약 한 2억 5천 정도
매각이 됐습니다.
>> 건물이 괜찮은데요? 네. 여기서
위치가 되게 괜찮아요. 역추구에서
바로 나오자마자 있고 245억이니까
>> 여기는 지형적 특성 때문에 건물 입질
거르기가 좀 힘들 것 같은데
>> 그죠. 여기 여기 이제 중간 정도는
살짝 떠요. 그래서 여기 보통 최근에
매각된 거 보면 한 1억 한 중후반
정도에 어 매각됐는데 저게 이제 제일
비싸게 어 매각된 그런 사례라고
보시면 될 거 같습니다. 그리고 오래
들어서 역대급 빌딩 거래된 금액이
있거든요. 최근에 여기 그 GS 타워
옆에 SI 타워가 매각이 됐습니다.
SI 타워가 어 8,971억 원에
매각이 됐어요. 비지스에서 매입한
것으로 알고 있는데 아마 전에 매입한
금액이 뭐 2009년도긴 하지만 한
4,억 정도에 매입을 했었습니다.
그래서 이번에 8,971억 원에
매각이 됐고 연면적당 가격으로 하는데
한 4,400만 원 4,500만 원선
되는 거 같습니다. 요겁니다. SI
타워. 요게 8,971억 원. 이번
분기에 10조원 넘었다 그랬잖아요.
매가를 많이 올린 매각된 사례 중에
좀 손꼽힐 만한 어 그 정도 금액대에
팔린 건물이라고 보시면 될 거
같아요. 올해 매각이 되었습니다.
그리고 여기가 이제 역삼역 쪽이고요.
역삼역 쪽에 또 매각된 사례가 몇 개
있어 가지고이 사례 같은 경우에는
올해 매각된 사례인데 어 정말 깜짝
놀랬어요. 어떻게 여기 이면에이 정도
금액이 매각되지 할 정도로 되게 깜짝
놀란 사례가 있어 가지고 한번 좀
들어가 보겠습니다. 강남 파이낸스
센터요 이면에 팔린 거 보고 진짜
깜짝 놀랐습니다. 보통은 금액이 한
500억 대면은 이면에 투자 잘 안
하거든요. 근데 500억 대각이
됐습니다. 그래서 510억 대에
매각이 됐는데 지금 요건물 있죠?
봐봐.
센터
>> 거. 예. 요게 요게 500억
넘게 거리게 됐어요.이 이면에이
500억 투자하기 쉽지 않거든요.이
상업지도 아니고. 보통 그 정도
금액되면 대로변을 사야 좀 황금성이
좋거든요. 그 나중에 저 500억대
사 가지고 600억 700억 그
이상에 팔아야 되는데 저기 이면에
저렇게 투자하기가 좀 쉽지 않아요.
나중에 팔기가 좀 쉽지 않을 것
같습니다. 제 생각에 이제 개인적인
생각입니다. 그리고 요거는 이제 저희
회사에서 최근에 중계했던 거지. 요거
요거요 위치 되게 좋은데 요거 요거
양꼬치집 있는 거요 140억 요거
위치 너무 좋습니다. 여기이면 테란노
이면인데 여기가 유동인구도 되게 많고
도로가 되게 괜찮아요. 딱 그 테라노
이면에 제일 넓은 도로입니다. 그래서
여기 코너 있는 건물을 어 제일
계산하게서 준비를 했었고 평단가도
되게 괜찮은 가격에 매입을 했어요.
그리고 이제 강남역 쪽으로
가보겠습니다. 여기 밑에까지
역삼동이거든요.
역삼로 더 지나서도 이제 역삼동인데
거기 밑에까지 가면은 진짜 금액이 뭐
50억 미만 30억대 건물들도 좀
있어요. 근데 거기 같은 경우에는 어
일단 역과의 거리도 되게 멀고
강남구라는 거 하나 때문에 투자하시는
분들이 꽤 많은데 아무래도 이렇게
나중에 매각하거나 뭐 임대하기에는 좀
쉽지 않은 그런 곳이라고 보시면 될
거 같아요.
네. 그래서 강남역 앞쪽에 왔습니다.
강남 대로를 기준으로 좌측이 이제
서초동이고 여기가 역삼동입니다. 여기
좌측인 서초동 같은 경우에는 이면까지
다 상업지어서 클럽이라든지 이런게 좀
많이 밀집되어 있어요. 근데 우측은
앞쪽만 상업지고 이면에는 다
3종입니다. 여기에는 뭐 클럽이
있거나 그런 건 아니고 대부분 다
먹자 상권은 어 여기 역삼동 쪽이
있다라고 보시면 될 거 같아요.
그래서 땅의 가치로만 봤을 때는 여기
서초동 쪽이 더 좋긴 하죠.도 다
상업지니까. 그리고 여기 이제 강남역
같은 경우에는 지금 임차인들 보시면
알겠지만 의원들이 되게 많아졌어요.
우리나라의 관광객들이 많아지고 그리고
이제 의류 관광화로 또 많이
오시거든요. 네. 그러면서
강남역의 이런 병원들이 굉장히
많아졌고 그중에 성형액과라든지
피부가들이 되게 많아졌습니다. 이제
이면을 올라가 보겠습니다.
보시면은 이렇게 먹자 상권이 많아요.
식당들이 좀 많이 일찍되어 있고 여기
보시면은 유동인가 그래도 조금
있습니다. 여기 이면도 그렇고
예전만큼은 아닌 거 같아요. 예전에
진짜 엄청 많았는데 물론 지금도 좀
있긴 하지만 사건들이 이면까지도
형성이 돼 있고 그리고 신기한게 이제
저기 위부터는 1일종이에요. 일종
지금 요거 연예인분 건물이죠. 여기
앞에 코너에 있는 건물 이제 연애분
건물인데
통임대로 인대료가 되게 높아야 한
거의 30만 원 되는 거 같은데
통임대로 맞춰졌습니다. 근데 이제 저
상태가 최적의 상태예요. 여기가 이제
여기는 일종 전용이거든요. 일종
전용은 용적률이 100%예요. 정말
최대의 건물 상태라고 보시면 될 거
같아요. 그러니까 이제 토지 활용도가
되게 좀 좋지 않은 어 그런
상황이라고 보시면 될 거 같고 그래서
어떻게 보면 더 개선할게 없는 거죠.
저 상태에서. 그래서 저거를 거의 뭐
90억대 사 가지고어 지금까지 가지고
있고 그리고 여기 원래 올라가서도
인차인들이 꽤 있었는데 여기 꽤 비어
있는 것들이 좀 많이 보이기
시작합니다. 여기가 언더길이 되게
심해. 지금 보세요. 지금 저기
보세요. 저기 거의 뭐 저기
스케이트장인 저기 거의 뭐 스키장인데
스키장. 그리고 저희가 예전에
중계했던 거 신축해 가지고 4억으로
옮겨줬고 원래 고시원이 있었어요.
그리고 요것도 이제 일종에 지은 거고
그때 다시 모게 사 가지고 신축한
건물입니다. 아무튼 그렇습니다.
그래서 어 역삼동을 좀 살짝
돌아봤는데 일단은 뭐 매각사도 좀 몇
개 설명드렸었고 되게 인상 깊뻤던 어
그런 매각사리들도 좀 보여 드렸는데
사실 역삼동이 되게 커요. 네. 그
밑에까지 보면은 되게 매각된 사례들도
많고 그래서 강남고에서 제일 거래가
많이 되는 동네 중에 하나요.
노년동이랑 역삼동. 네. 그래서 그
정도로 투자자들이 많이 찾는 그런
동네라고 보시면 될 거 같습니다.
그래서 오늘 영상은 여기까지 하고요.
지금이 영상을 보시는 분들 중에
혹시이 동네는 좀 궁금하다라고 하시는
분 계시면은 댓글 남겨 주시면 그쪽에
또가 가지고 제가 드라이브수를 하도록
하겠습니다. 오늘 영상 여기까지
하겠습니다. 감사합니다.
[음악]